inflation certainly taking a toll on all
of us especially business owners who in
many cases have to figure out how to
stay afloat right so our mary jane
ballieza is live at a family-owned farm
in the middle of the city talking about
the impact of those food and gas prices
on their business hi mary jane
hi there nate we're here at jr pony
parties in the northwest side of the
valley i'm joined bright and early this
morning with kathleen meehan her and her
family own this farm and kathleen thank
you so much for joining us here
good morning to dolly too she's oh my
gosh she's busy eating up all the grass
and everything here in the yard and
that's one thing as we know that
food costs for the animals have really
gone up i know for the price of hay you
were telling me has pretty much doubled
yeah it's gone up over a hundred dollars
what above what i used to pay
and that's and i just worry i know gas
may come down but does that gonna bring
our prices down i don't know i hope it
does but right now it's just i've had to
raise my prices in 25 years i've never
had to
raise my prices but i have to in 25
years i've got to to cover the cost of
taking care of the animals here well
that makes it hard too how can you keep
your business going you know if if you
can't do anything about that so you're
forced to raise your prices i'm forced
to raise my prices and i just hope with
you know the kids and everybody that
wants to come in here understand i had
to there's nothing i could do about it
and what people don't know either is
that you also take in rescue so you're
taking in more animals that means the
cost is going up for food and people
don't understand that that's a big
commitment it's a commitment of their
whole life so you take a horse or a pony
they live 30 years if not more or less
that is a commitment of your life for 30
years and you have to take that and that
with dogs and cats if you take an animal
in know that you have a commitment just
don't take it like oh i want to oh it's
so cute no it is a commitment of love
and
just take care of them oh yeah
absolutely and i can see how much love
you know you put into your animals and
dolly of course she's one of the she
look at her she's just pretty much eaten
away you can tell she's pretty committed
to to being here as well because she's
just so good with the kids like you were
mentioning she is so good and she's well
loved and she's always asked for or we
got some others out there that are
always asked for too we people have
their favorites and we we will bring out
their favorites oh perfect thank you so
much kathleen we appreciate it reporting
live mary jane bellassa live local now
wow she's so soft
she is soft dolly they're enjoying her
early breakfast all right thank you
actress
has died hours after being taken off
life support actress suffered severe
brain injuries and burns after a fiery
crash in l.a earlier this month she was
declared brain dead last week she's best
known for her roles in another world and
several films including six days seven
nights she also had a public
relationship with ellen degeneres in the
late 90s and he was 53 years old very
sad news
firefighters have stopped forward
progress on a brush fire up near reno
the fire started yesterday afternoon in
galena creek regional park it only grew
to a few acres thankfully the fire did
destroy one structure though fire crews
are still there they're putting out hot
spots investigators say they do not know
what started that fire but everybody is
very nervous about fire season always
nate they should be 5 41 now on your
monday morning back here at home
southern nevada health district telling
us their east las vegas center is shut
down today because they need to fix a
broken water line they're hoping it's
just a one day deal but say the building
could be shut down for several days if
you have an appointment there
you're supposed to be contacted for
rescheduling you can always go to their
main location of course that's decatur
south of the 95.
to unlv now officially an entirely
smoke-free campus the new policy applies
to everybody that's students and faculty
and visitors too
it includes tobacco marijuana and
e-cigarettes they're encouraging
everybody to quit and if you want to
quit here's the number 1-800 quit now
heather coming up commitment to
excellence why raiders head coach josh
mcdaniels is calling yesterday's
preseason game the most interesting he
has ever been a part of
plus aces high las vegas aces lock up
the number one overall seed in the
playoffs we've got highlights of their
big win
weekdays at nine
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now
you know thousands of children end up in
the emergency room every year with bike
injuries and the american academy of
pediatrics still talking about how
critical it is that the kids have
helmets on more from elise preston
four-year-old harrison fleming has been
perfecting his two-wheeling all summer
his dad eric makes sure he always wears
a helmet we're lucky enough to live on a
dead end here
where there's not much traffic but
accidents can always happen bicycle
riding is one of the leading causes of
sport related head injuries in children
a new american academy of pediatrics
report is highlighting the research that
helmets significantly reduce risks of
traumatic brain injury while bike riding
or taking part in other sports bicycle
helmets are extremely effective in
protecting head injuries when you look
at all that data together about 90
percent of brain injuries can be
prevented by wearing a helmet but it's
not just your brain
about 65 of facial injuries can be
prevented despite the evidence one study
shows only 42 percent of children always
wear a bike helmet 30 percent never wear
one 21 states and the district of
columbia have laws requiring children of
certain ages to wear a helmet while
biking i would sort of say treat it like
a seat belt so insist that your child
wear it every time also try to make it
fun you can actually choose the helmet
with your child dr lois lee is an er
physician at boston children's hospital
she says the helmet should cover the
forehead above the eyebrows straps flat
against the head with the divider under
the ears and only two fingers should fit
between the chin and chin strap eric
hopes harrison will always choose to
protect himself i hope he hears a helmet
his entire life i mean there's no i
don't think just an age limit on safety
because it's better to be safe than
sorry elise preston cbs news new york
las vegas aces defeated the seattle
storm in the regular season finale 109
to 100 becky hammond's first season is
head coach and the team claims the
league's best record the stars were out
for the game on the visitor side 13-time
all-star sue bird playing in her final
regular season game but the player of
the game chelsea gray one of the best
passers in the league showing she can
get the job done herself aces close the
season with a four-game win streak asia
wilson kelsey plun the first teammates
ever to both score 700 points in the
same season next aces have a three-game
series with the phoenix mercury in the
first round the winner will face either
the storm or mistake for a chance to
advance to the finals
i've been
around a lot of preseason games over 22
years and i don't remember one feeling
like this
so we go from basketball to football
obviously coach josh mcdaniels of the
raiders after their 26-20 win yesterday
at legion stadium over the vikings
pretty impressive second preseason game
five of their seven possessions resulted
in points
no turnovers second week in a row and
now of course it is just a preseason but
pretty encouraging signs for team with a
new head coach next game for the raiders
traveling to miami taking on the
dolphins on saturday heather if you were
at the game yesterday you got to see
this pretty cool more than 500 former
raiderettes in attendance for the
special 60th reunion at allegiance
stadium cheerleaders from every decade
came together to light the al davis
memorial tour to perform a halftime
routine
the raiderettes have cheered on the
raiders since the 1960s
boy they have some stamina too don't
they look at that that's great love it
hey once a raiderette always a
raiderette
although if you're carrying around the
pom-poms and doing the shimmy in the
kitchen i'm not sure
hey no judgment nobody else needs that
i'm sure the family likes it at home
paula abdul there i'm like she was a
laker yeah
close frontie
wrong sport he dried thanks mitchell
good job
donald veil
that was great that was quite a
spectacle though yesterday thank you you
were saying that the football field was
pretty much full of later rats 500 yeah
that's a lot
well let's hope everybody had a good
weekend it was an interesting weekend
right lots of clouds
saturday for sure wow crazy that held
back temperatures to 90 degrees
beautiful this morning we've got a lot
of humidity out there clouds still left
over in the skies and we're starting to
see a little bit of early color now that
we've got some light going on out there
definitely made a difference in our
temperatures though over the weekend
with mid 90s on friday and upper
actually upper 90s friday mid 90s
yesterday and just 90 degrees on
saturday with those clouds we've got a
mix kind of of a lot of upper 70s and
just a few neighborhoods low 80s like
green valley sunrise mountain and nellis
and downtown 71 also out at red rock
this morning humidity's up it's over 60
percent we're still very muggy monsoon
is not going anywhere this week we're
still looking for a chance of afternoon
and evening thunderstorms mid 70's in
mesquite had over a third of an inch of
rain up there last night mid 70's in
indian springs 78 in pram 77 in sandy
valley 81 right now in laughlin 68 in
kingman 99 out at death valley just
updated all the numbers 63 up there in
cali any 62 in tonepaw heat advisories
some are still hanging on through the
deep south even heat advisories issued
for a central
the interior of california now that's
tuesday through friday a lot of heat
building with high pressure there
showers and thunderstorms through the
plains and see this tropical moisture
swirling in texas that's going to get
caught up in the monsoon flow and
influence our weather this week because
it's going to enhance more of the
moisture by the end of the week in the
monsoon flow so a big flare look at all
of the lightning across arizona
yesterday and again last night we had
some thunderstorms traveling right
through the moapa valley and that was
pretty intense with the lightning and
strong winds but again over a third of
an inch of rain and most recently we've
seen cells right here around the nevada
arizona border just east of lake mead
but they're not going to make it into
the valley at least not this morning
flood watches are still posted for
northwest arizona those for clark county
from sunday those expired at 1 a.m so no
flood watches in place for us i want to
show you something that happened really
really cool though did you get outside
over the weekend try to watch the
perseids meteor showers you know it was
hard saturday night but we've had some
clear skies
check that out
do you see that there was a huge boom up
in snow basin utah north of salt lake
city
that was a meteor that exploded and made
this incredibly loud noise
and it was confirmed by the national
weather service that it was part of the
perseids and one of those stray meteors
and it looked like it even fell during
the day
which is very unusual the perseids
peaked over the weekend
if you get away at night time and away
from the dark city lights you could see
up to 200 an hour it's one of the best
shows of the year but unfortunately this
year it had the bright moonlight with it
as well 100 degrees today tomorrow
wednesday 102 good chance of
thunderstorms especially today then at
least slight chances through the weekend
mid 90s showing up by the weekend also
chances of thunderstorms especially on
saturday all right let's get to the
roads at 5 52. okay a couple of things
going on one of them's cleared up one of
them is still working generally the
freeway is in pretty good shape we're
trying to get you safely out the door
here before 6 a.m as we start the second
week of classes in the school district
remember school zones are for real stop
on 15 you've got some company earlier
crash we're talking about now gone
the ramp from sunset to get onto the
northbound 95 515 wide open there not
much going on however we still have a
complete closure of charleston and
valley view so it's off the freeways
originally reported as a crash now it
turns out it was police activity don't
know for sure what's going on i thought
i saw somebody picking up some cones
here but both north and southbound
valley view are closed as is east and
westbound charleston so how are you
going to get around we're suggesting for
east west travel with charleston close
go up to alta or down to okie or sahara
with valley view closed for north south
travel head east over to rancho or west
to decatur no word when that's going to
reopen heather all right coming up here
at six a big change happening in late
night tell you who's leaving the late
show with stephen colbert stay with
live
this is good day las vegas
now
all right so even if you're not sam i am
you can choose to like or dislike green
eggs and ham
in the house of the guy who made that
combination famous sherry he sure did
this is kind of a cool house dr seuss's
former home is up for sale in san diego
dr seuss purchased this home in 1947.
he lived there until 1991 while he
worked on many of his best selling books
inside the upstairs studio of this
mansion it's 5 000 square feet sits on
four acres atop mount soledad three
bedrooms offices a pool
270 degree panoramic views overlooking
la jolla coast
18 million dollars and it comes with a
cat and a hat
now
and now on good day las vegas panic
after reports of shots fired at reed
international airport false alarm caused
major delays we'll tell you what's
happening there this morning
plus inflation issues we're live with
how one family-owned farm is trying to
cope with these higher prices and
cannabis lounges back on clark county's
agenda the regulations that need to be
ironed out before dispensaries can apply
to open a lounge here in the valley good
day las vegas starts right now
now
this is good day las vegas live local
now we want to welcome you in here on
this monday morning it is six o'clock
john has a day off so we got this yes we
got this it's muggy i feel like we're
slogging through a swamp in here kind of
like you have to do this when you're
walking through just the air
nothing has really changed in the last
few years seems like we're stuck here
yeah it is we are stuck with monsoon
season which is not a bad thing no no we
need it it brought us some really nice
rainfall
not really much over the weekend as far
as valley rain we've had thunderstorms
around us up in the mountains and some
passing last night beautiful skies
though
look at that gorgeous light out there
with the clouds
currently temperatures right now down
into the mid 70s and we still have a
couple of neighborhoods stuck right in
the low 80s but these temperatures are
not bad for morning temps 67 humidity
though and that dew point is up to 64
now so we definitely have a lot of juice
out there to work with to get
thunderstorms going again today sunrise
at 5 59 sunset at 7 31.
we do feel that moisture and that
humidity and last night we did have
those thunderstorms up in the moapa
valley lots of lightning over a third of
an inch of rain most recently we've seen
a few showers now right over here east
of lake mead and they continue to slide
south away from boulder city and the las
vegas valley so we're not worried about
getting that rain through your morning
commute we will be partly cloudy to
mostly sunny as we get through the
morning hours 87 by 9 a.m 90s by noon
and yes that daytime heating will start
to cook up that moisture have a little
energy coming our way later this
afternoon into tonight could cook up
those thunderstorms about a 30 percent
chance high of 100 for your monday
afternoon hot and humid and sticky yes
yes that
good news for the freeways you are in
pretty good shape as you're getting up
and adam here just a reminder we're
starting week two
of the school year so those flashing
lights are for real you got some company
stop on on the 15 heading out of the
spaghetti bowl we did have an issue with
the complete shutdown of the
intersection of charleston and
valleyview some police activity the good
news that has completely cleared
whatever they were doing there they took
the yellow tape down you're looking at
southbound valley view here at
charleston i take that back this is
eastbound charleston that used to be a
pdq printing and that used to be the m m
soul food restaurant okay the rest of
the freeway system in pretty good shape
here as you're getting going here on a
monday morning we're watching it for you
all morning long heather ever need a
restaurant nate knows where it is
well chaos at reed international after a
false report of shots fired this morning
things are back to normal but the
confusion early yesterday morning caused
a ripple effect of delays and
cancellations impacting flights most of
the day the noise later determined to be
something else not gunfire but some
passengers however rushed through tsa in
a panic it all caused tsa to call back
multiple passengers for screening at
security checkpoints and several flights
were delayed or canceled as a result the
person responsible for the loud noise is
now in custody
metro police have identified the five
officers who exchanged gunfire with a
robbery suspect during a crosstown very
wild chase here's a list of the officers
that were involved on your screen
the chase started thursday night near
pecos and cheyenne police say the
suspect carjacked someone at gunpoint
the chase ended near charleston and
decatur when the suspect crashed into an
officer's car injuring an officer and
his k-9 both are expected to be ok the
suspect is in court or in custody rather
federal law enforcement officials are
facing threats after searching former
president trump's florida estate now
lawmakers are demanding more
transparency into that investigation
here's bradley blackburn with details
it's outrageous rhetoric the fbi and
department of homeland security are on
high alert following the search of
former president trump's mar-a-lago
estate last week everybody needs to
respect our law enforcement whether it
be local
state or federal a joint intelligence
bulletin sent to law enforcement across
the country warned of a threat to place
a so-called dirty bomb in front of fbi
headquarters and general calls for civil
war and armed rebellion other threats
are also circulating online former fbi
agent turned pennsylvania congressman
brian fitzpatrick discussed the
development on face the nation i myself
have been notified by the bureau that my
life was put in danger
recently
by some of these same people the warrant
unsealed friday detailed agents
retrieved close to two dozen boxes of
material containing 11 sets of
classified documents some marked top
secret anyone in the intelligence
community that had
documents like that they would be under
serious investigation on social media mr
trump alleged agents knowingly
confiscated privileged attorney-client
material writing i respectfully request
that these documents be immediately
returned this is a law enforcement
matter and the department of justice is
going to move forward as they see fit
over the weekend a bipartisan call for
more transparency senate intelligence
committee chairs democrat mark warner
and republican marco rubio requested the
release of the classified documents in
question to committee members along with
an assessment of how their mishandling
might impact national security bradley
blackburn cbs news new york republicans
are calling on the doj to release the
affidavit that led to that search
warrant no charges have been filed
against the former president nate back
here at home heather a six-year-old boy
is dead after a hit-and-run crash near
sahara and maryland parkway this was
just before 5 30 saturday evening metro
police say the kid fell off his bike and
then was hit by a truck taken to a
hospital didn't survive police did track
down an arrest the driver he's
identified as 20 year old mike 21 year
old michael burdick he is facing hit and
run charges to the southwest valley for
a road project aimed at improving
pedestrian and bike safety in the far
southwest valley the ford apache project
running from warm springs down to near
wigwam it includes new bike lanes new
sidewalks new street lights and of
course more lanes for cars here's clark
county commissioner justin jones
there were multiple incidences in which
there were cyclists who were hit in that
area uh and i think the thing that sort
of caps encapsulated everything is there
was a a hand-painted sign on the side of
the road that says please fix this road
and that was uh that was the really what
what put it in perspective is that
someone took the time to to go
hand paid a sign and put it out there
we talked about this they actually did
blasting on there to take away some of
the mountain and the next phase the
project will extend all of the
improvements
from wigwam down to blue diamond road
sherry
you know they're desperate if they're
going to put their own hand painted sign
out there
inflation is hitting one long time local
business really hard mary jane belliesa
is live with a family-owned farm in the
northwest valley with how higher gas and
food prices are really taking a bite out
of her business mary jane tell us and
show us more
well she i'm sure you guys can hear all
the noises that the animals are making
bright early this morning they want you
to wake up here as we get the day
started i'm here in the northwest valley
with kathleen meehan she is the owner of
jr pony parties and kathleen i know that
you and your family have owned this
business for such a long time and you
mentioned that this past summer was
really slow just because of all the gas
and food impacts really hitting your
business it did it was very slow slower
than most summers i mean most of my day
camps that i have here are pretty much
full and i
had empty day camps this year
and i think because we started to open
up and then and we don't know what to
expect with the gas prices the economy
prices on everything food and i think it
was really slow so i'm hoping next year
guys day camp it's really lots of fun i
know it looks like that ducks have a lot
of fun
and i know too kathleen that also you
take donations and then that will really
help with the animals it will help a lot
to getting donations from the from
everybody here in las vegas with the
prices of everything's gone up
everything's gone up just like for your
food their food has gone up as well yeah
people don't know that you've taken
rescue so not only are you feeding in
the animals that you already have but
that means taking in new animals and
you're making a commitment if you say
yes to taking in an animal you've got 20
years of a commitment to take care of
this animal for the rest of their life
and that's what it takes to be a rescue
person
the commitment and also for people who
want to help me donate please because it
will help me keep these guys going and
i've made my commitment to take care of
them so that's perfect well kathleen i
know now speeding times will probably
get feeding to the animals very soon i
know this one's
right hungry
getting ready to eat soon thanks so much
kathleen you're welcome thank you
reporting live mary jane vallisa live
local now
a very chatty death this morning mary
jane thank you that's great
clark county commissioners will be
discussing licensing for cannabis
lounges during their upcoming meeting
it's tomorrow
the county though still ironing out just
how it will regulate these cannabis
lounges licensing department will
discuss changes that need to be made to
the county's code and that needs to
happen before dispensaries can apply to
open a lounge cannabis consumers say
there is a need for those lounges here
in the valley
you know what i'm saying because there's
some people that can't smoke in their
apartment complexes and places like that
you know what i'm saying so they should
be able to come out and you don't smoke
so i heard that i got a law that you
can't smoke in public
if y'all get a lounge
that'd be that'd be clutch other heavy
smokers like myself
an abbey clutch
in order for cannabis lounges to open in
clark county businesses will have to
follow special protocols including
having specially trained staff and be a
certain distance away from schools among
other things
6 10 this morning we're getting our look
now first look at this new resort that
is coming to the southwest valley yeah
it's called durango station at red rock
resort it's 750 million dollars 71 acres
of land this is down in the southwest by
durango in the 215
the casino 100 000 square feet they'll
also have convention space entertainment
space and of course restaurants duh
hey guess what it's even gonna have a
pool there it is it's supposed to open
next year and here's even a better thing
for our economy one thousand jobs to our
area yeah that's a good thing yes we can
use it but it is a nice looking resort
too for sure see come up
and speaking of coming out popular show
on this trip celebrating 800
performances all right we'll also show
you strip headliner derek huff how he is
inspiring the next generation of dancers
what advice did he give them to strive
to their goals that is so exciting but
first we gotta first check on the
forecast and sherry's gotta look it's a
muggy it's human
sure is guys i thought derek huff was
the next generation gosh even he's
getting older
time goes fast doesn't it beautiful
skies this morning i tell you what's not
going fast is this humidity moving out
we're stuck with it and that's okay if
it brings us some more rain there were
thunderstorms last night there are some
showers off to the east of las vegas and
there are more in the forecast for your
monday
and lots of days in the eight day
forecast check it out i've got your most
accurate forecast coming back after the
break we're live local now
eight years in a row
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now well
you might have heard the late show band
leader john baptiste is leaving the
program after seven seasons says he
wants to focus more on his own music
most recently he won five awards
including album of the year at the
grammys louie cato who's been filling in
on the late show this summer will take
over as band later new season in the
late show premieres september 6 but
right here on cbs all right here at home
the folks from life is beautiful as well
as local artists are going to be
unveiling a new mural later today on the
east valley near washington and lamb at
shelby park there it is on your map
they're just trying to keep las vegas
beautiful and they're going to have the
unveiling at nine o'clock this morning
heather something to check out vegas
headliner and dancing with the stars pro
derek huff surprised a group of ballet
students at nevada ballet over the
weekend he gave the young dancers
private lessons and also shared some of
the secrets to his success
it's not all just about the success and
all these different things it's about
the love of dance it's about the passion
of dance it's about the work ethic and
the discipline
but more importantly it's it's
it's just that love that love of dance
hell that he has it that's for sure what
a fun day for these kids
he is performing still at the venetian
as part of his no limit residency you
can check it out through september 10th
tickets on sale through ticketmaster i
highly recommend it oh i can't wait to
see it he just shows up in his khaki
shorts huh
and the kids are going who's that guy oh
i think they were i think they were
thrilled they know that's derek sure
potted potter the harry potter parody
celebrated 800 shows wow that was at
valleys over the weekend where they
performed the show also recently
celebrated its third anniversary so it's
been a while around for a while it's
extended its run in bally's through
january and you can catch the show every
evening except on wednesday there are
also matinee performances great show for
the kids it's funny tuesday saturday and
sunday they have the matinee
performances so check it out these guys
are super talented we've had them here
in the studio and with all of those
available performances i have no excuse
for having missed the show no that is
true yeah these guys i mean if john
langley were sitting here he would have
an excuse to miss the show because he
just misses everything well i don't know
he probably hasn't even seen a harry
potter yeah
because we love john of course we oh
well he's enjoying that three day
weekend yes we had a good weekend it was
kind of you know it felt short well
saturday i got a little drizzle on
saturday yes there were some light
sprinkles a little light rain the clouds
were around all day long it almost
looked like a little smoke in the air
too uh none that we were aware of but it
was just a smoke i mean i'm sorry it was
just an overcast cloudy day this morning
we've got a few clouds around kind of a
partly cloudy sky to get our monday
started and humid oh my goodness
humidity is over 60 dew points in the
60s the east valley neighborhoods just
right close to 80 degrees but everybody
else is in the 70s this morning not much
in the way of wind mesquite you had some
rain overnight so that was nice to pick
up some rain but you probably had some
loud thunder with that lightning too 76
right now mid 70s for indian springs
pahrump on the back side of the
mountains 78 degrees had some big
thunderstorms in the mountains yesterday
over an inch of rain up there at mount
charleston 77 in boulder city 81 in
laughlin with some 60s in kingman and
northwest arizona again will be prime
for big thunderstorms that could drop
some heavy rain back on friday just
right around the dinner hour we added
another 100 of an inch to our official
rain totals
we're doing great for august almost
two-thirds of an inch of rain we're
sitting at close to an inch and a half
for the year
and still over an inch behind but boy
we've made up for what we were behind a
lot during the monsoon season so we've
had a very healthy monsoon season and
i'm going to call your attention to some
rain in texas because i think we're
going to get a good taste of it by the
end of the week otherwise showers and
thunderstorms through the rockies and
the plains more heat advisories through
the deep south and we are looking at a
tropical system it's got a lot of
tropical moisture with it right over
south west texas it's going to get
caught up in the monsoon flow and help
add to the moisture and the energy for
us by the end of the week and enhance
our chances for thunderstorms out of the
monsoon southeast flow so today we'll be
looking at pretty good chances in the
afternoon and evening but yesterday look
at all of that lightning
around arizona from southwest utah now
again we had heavy rain in the mountains
good thunderstorms overnight in the
moapa valley and a few showers right now
east of lake mead and again the heavier
rain focusing over northwest arizona
with flood watches in place all the way
until 10 o'clock our flood watch that
was in place for clark county in on
sunday uh was allowed to expire at 1 a.m
we'll be looking for 100 degrees today
you know the danger this time of year is
the lightning that would start fires and
that's what we've been so worried about
a fire up in southeast washington state
this is a grass fire that got up over 20
acres yesterday and you can see it
burning in the night firefighters have
been on it they don't know what got it
started it did burn one structure so
they're trying to get it out as fast as
they can but boy the wind's just ripping
it through the hillsides there of
southeast washington so that's always
our fear with lightning is starting
wildfires in areas and and fires in
areas that haven't had a lot of rain
we've got the chance of thunderstorms
every day this week triple digits the
first half of the week and then back to
90s to finish the week so just keep an
eye to the sky outdoors in the afternoon
and evenings and listen to the forecast
please 6 21 let's hit the drive all
right so we're actually doing very well
here for a monday morning coming up on 6
30. i don't want to jinx anything but
the no crash is working right now you do
have slow downs up in the centennial
bowl you drive up there where the 95
meets the northern 215 beltway you know
what i'm talking about just follow the
signs here there are a few more cars
getting onto the roadways but i don't
think it's a holiday that just appears
to be not a ton of traffic we have a
live picture for you here this is uh
both north and south on i-15 southbound
on the right-hand side obviously there's
the rio down there and the palms
northbounders heading into the spaghetti
bowl everybody doing a great job of
behaving themselves and don't forget it
is the second week of the clark county
school district and as we get the second
week of classes underway we're going to
talk about uh one person who apparently
didn't get the message when it comes to
flashing lights in school zones that's
coming up on what's driving you crazy
next on good day las vegas
4 on 8 news now
coming up on 6 26 on your monday morning
well we are starting week 2 of the new
school year with a big time what were
you thinking moment in a ccsd school
zone this is from last friday
metro police social media posting a car
taken off our streets after going nearly
quadruple the school zone speed limit
saying
when the lights are flashing it's not a
suggestion if you choose to drive 97 in
a 25 mile an hour school zone you
choose a ride to the clark county
detention center
wow okay nobody was hurt in this
situation but the social media post does
point out that seven pedestrians died on
our roads just last week buckle up drive
carefully pay attention to the school
zones and put down that phone you can
join the driving crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com
just ahead our las vegas aces one step
closer advancing to the wnba finals
we've got highlights from the wind
against the seattle storm on good day
las vegas
between 11 a.m and 7 p.m in summer
now on good day chaos at the airport
thousands of travelers outraged after a
false alarm snowballs into hundreds of
flight delays and even cancellations at
reid international
plus a helping hand a local non-profit
tried to do their part to help anyone
who may be in danger by living in the
flood channels
also inflated farms a local farm
business handling increased prices it's
tough we'll tell you how they can keep
putting smiles on kids faces go day las
vegas starts right now
now
this is good day las vegas live local
now all right the sun is up hopefully
you're up 6 30. i know mondays are tough
right they are and i was kind of
following on social media all that stuff
going on at the airport yesterday oh
yeah there had to be so many frustrated
people with that absolutely crazy my
in-laws left late saturday night which
is good because they would have gotten
caught up on a melee
scary i'm sure for folks going through
tsa once is bad enough and go through it
twice no fun
yes well weather-wise we've been sticky
all weekend clouds on saturday yesterday
more sunshine the mornings though have
been nice and this morning very very
nice if you don't mind the humidity out
there beautiful skies looking out over
the southwest valley the mountains
getting a lot of rain again yesterday
big thunderstorms heavy rain up at mount
charleston over an inch of rain
temperatures this morning
in the 70s in fact we've got more 70s
than 80s not much in the way of wind boy
that humidity is high though it's over
60 percent showers and thunderstorms off
to the east of the las vegas valley
overnight in fact the moapa valley
clobbered with big thunderstorms over a
third of an inch of rain and some
showers on the most recent radar right
here east of lake mead pretty much
weakening now and will miss the valley
even missing boulder city this morning
so the morning commute just fine
weather-wise if you don't mind it being
a little sticky out there 79 kiddos the
average temperature mostly sunny through
the morning and we'll be looking for a
hot day at about 100 degrees including
the humidity that makes it even a little
more uncomfortable chance of
thunderstorms again through the
afternoon hours and right on into the
evening and that's going to stay
really we could even see thunderstorms
later than usual 6 31 good morning nate
how are the roads the roads are dry
that's the good news and we are crash
free don't want to jinx anything but if
you're getting up and at them and you're
fixing to get out
all the freeways are wide open with the
exception of course of the centennial
bowl all of the cones up there you just
follow the detours and you get through
okay had an earlier crash down in the
southeast an intersection closed off the
freeways but so far so good here as
you're getting going at 6 30.
the southbound side of i-15
pretty nice in both directions here we
are looking south these are the
taillights now here's a nevada state
police highway patrol officer where
somebody pulled over to the side of the
road if they stay there you'll be just
fine might be a little bit of an issue
if you're trying to get on from sahara
to get onto the southbound freeway
northbound side looking really good rest
the freeway system in good shape now
heather all right nate we appreciate
that it is business as usual reid
international this morning almost 24
hours after panic forced hundreds of
flight delays metro police say a loud
noise prompted passengers hundreds of
them to flee they were concerned it was
gunshots officers say though no shots
were fired but the panic it forced all
gates to be evacuated and that means
that every single passenger had to go
back through security a second time and
that snowball effect led to delays
cancellations and as you might imagine
some frustrated passengers
we've been coming here for 42 years and
it was crazy yeah they need better
communication here because really nobody
knew what was going on and you know
which direction everybody was to go
metro police say the person who caused
that loud noise was taken into custody
overall more than 500 flights were
delayed 62 more
were canceled so taking a live look now
at the board it appears as though
everything is back to normal at read
international this morning flights are
arriving on time but as always a
reminder if you are headed out to the
airport just check with your airline or
check with the airport before you do so
to avoid any unnecessary waiting
metro police identified the officers
involved in a high-speed chase that
involved gunfire and ended with a crash
last week happened thursday ending on
decatur near charleston two officers
were hurt during that chase we're told
they will be okay the suspect is behind
bars so here's a list of the five
officers that were involved each having
between one and seven years with the
force petro says all of them are right
now on paid administrative leave sherry
monsoon season still in full swing with
our flood channels seeing a lot of
flowing water through the channels this
summer and that makes them a dangerous
place to be especially for our homeless
population who live in flood channel
tunnels
two people were found dead inside a
flood channel this month the danger has
a local non-profit stepping up to help
shine a light provides referrals that
help community partners reach out to the
homeless
officials there say it's about making a
connection then lending a hand to help
they're pretty broken they've been
struggling with homelessness addiction
mental health and multitudes of
different things with our donations
we're not going to provide them with
enough stuff for a week
even for a few days it's more just the
key to the door
being able to have a conversation with
them by coming up to them giving them a
bottle of water
this year shine a light has helped more
than 200 people thanks to donations and
you can learn more about the group at
eight newsnow dot com heather
this morning three people are recovering
after being shot at six flags in
illinois the shooter still not in
custody police say it happened outside
of the park it appears to be an isolated
incident the two teens that were hit
will be okay a third declined treatment
officers evacuated the park when they
arrived no word if that park is
reopening this morning
a traffic stop ends with a man behind
bars and dozens of firearms seized in
northern nevada it happened friday near
wells which is in the northeast part of
the state nevada state police say they
found 38 guns seven pounds of marijuana
and more than 12 thousand dollars in
cash says 24 year old tristan steinman
who was arrested facing now several
charges
turning to health now monkey pox cases
continue to go up here in clark county
and across the country the southern
nevada health district says there are
currently 75 cases of the virus here
locally that was as of friday the health
district does have limited supplies of a
monkey pox vaccine but it's only
available to anyone who's had either
close contact with someone that has it
or is suspected of having the virus
well one of those recent cases within
the clark county school district the
principal of palo verde high school was
alerted and alerted parents on friday
ccsd is working with the southern nevada
health district on all contact tracing
with that person who has it so they will
notify any parents or students who need
to be monitored or tested doctors say
the risk of monkey pox transmission
still remains low
6 36 inflation hitting one local
business at an all-time high our mary
jane valezia live at a family-owned farm
in the middle of the city talking about
how gas and food prices are hurting
their business but how you can help
what's the deal mary jane
yeah nate i mean you're absolutely right
i'm here in the northwest valley in the
part of town i am joined bright and
early this morning with kathleen meeham
her and her family owned jr pony parties
and of course we have another special
guest here with
ellie
she's already looking at me wondering if
i have any food oh and i do have some
food
and kathleen i know we talked a lot
about the inflation impacts on your
business especially with birthday
parties i mean it's been slow this
summer for you it's been really slow
when i get it it's hot but you know what
guys the weather's changing it's going
to start getting cooler because my guys
are already shedding so i know winter's
coming and you know book your birthday
parties they're private they're uh three
hours and we run the whole venue we make
a big deal out of the birthday child but
we also put parents back to the party so
they don't miss out on anything which is
important because sometimes when we're
running around for our kids we miss out
on those special times but we're going
to put you back in there lots of pony
rides the petting zoo the goats feeding
animals it's a blast here and as we know
too i mean with any type of business
you're hopefully waiting for it to pick
up as september comes that way you can
keep the animals going as well because a
lot goes into it you got to pay for
their food and you also take in other
animals as well absolutely it takes a
lot of time and a lot of money and a lot
of food to keep these guys all
comfortable and living happy
and you do take donations too yes we do
that's perfect and they can just send
them to jay our pony parties our address
is on our website that's perfect i know
she's probably wanting more grass here
right or they can give me a call too
702-631-4142 that's perfect well
kathleen thank you so much appreciate it
for having me thank you for coming and
seeing my animals perfect reporting live
mary jane bellassa live local now
at least she's got well i know for the
forecast from now on i'm just gonna go
see kathleen and the llamas and the
ponies all the animals that are shedding
i'll know when it's getting cooler
firefighters